obviously I love the Americans I love uh
Perry Mason and I love the take on it I
love that the first season was about
it's the origin story which I thought
was brilliantly done yes and uh and now
that that's been settled you're off and
running which is fantastic but I must
mention your stunning cameo in cocaine
Bear yes yes hey I want to stop by
saying
when I I read I read the script and then
that one of the first lines is Andrew
Thornton the second so if you Google
Andrew Thornton II
surely as already said I've pitched this
to Elizabeth Banks I said we have to do
the prequel that leads up to that moment
where he's throwing cocaine because he's
a fascinating story oh my God yes he's
unbelievable but the film opens and I
don't think I'm spoiling much of
anything but I you know I was uh you
know I would have I'll I'll go see you
in anything so did I not know uh that
you know um Elizabeth Banks I'm I'm
friendly with her and I was excited to
see cocaine Baron I really enjoyed it
and so the whole thing was a success but
if I hadn't known any of those things
and I just heard that you were in this
movie I'd have said well it's it's
Matthew Reese I gotta go check it out
and so I would go
and here's you were gone very quickly
yes instantly in a way that's hilarious
yes but it was very strategic because I
was getting shooting in Ireland Island
was being shot as Appalachia obviously
right um and I've been I've been with
the kids going to various aquariums for
some time and I'd read the script and
I'd and in passing I said who's playing
that who's playing under the under
Thornton the second she's like who's he
I was like the guy the guy the guy at
the beginning the whole reason for this
film right and she's like I don't I I
don't know I'll ask but I was like text
pranks now Stephen she goes we haven't
even cast it yet so I said tell do I'll
do it I'll do it because it would mean
half a day away from the children Kerry
wasn't in the scene and I knew I could
get like a solid three quarters of a day
on my own yes and that that was really
sole reason for doing it and then you
held out for 10 million dollars I did I
did you got it I got it I got it but I
think it was worth it I think I think I
I was with him and I had a lot of it's
the best 80 Seconds Of My Life of my
life that's all my real is now is that
80 Seconds
um we're talking about uh you know this
Antique Motorcycle reminds me that I
heard that you got yourself this boat
recently yeah and I love the way you got
the boat which is it it started which is
a deadly combination I think were you on
were you on the internet and was drink
involved and late at night yes yes yes
it was actually Welsh whiskey I hastened
to add right I don't usually drink so I
count that as part of this madness
befell me but I was I I do I do
occasionally like to look at all old
boats
um and and I was I was looking and I'm a
little bit of a Hemingway fan and I saw
this boat which I I knew Hemingway had a
Wheeler Playmate and I saw a Wheeler
playmate for sale on eBay and I knew
there's very few around
this boat was also called rare bit now I
don't know if you know the dish Welsh
rare bit yeah and she was named rabbit
in 1939 which was built in Brooklyn and
so many planets were aligning and
colliding oh that's what that's that's a
voice from Beyond saying this you have
to do this right and that's what I told
Carrie in the morning I said what did I
have to do this that I had done it
reeking of alcohol yes I've bought a
boat and she's like you don't even row I
was like oh it's beyond rowing oh we're
not talking about no growing no no we
shall take family trips to this
so yeah so I embarked on this four-year
Odyssey of Madness where I've restored
the where I've restored this book one
myself and the captain did she's she she
kind of spearheaded the restoration
because so many things went wrong we
started out with a shipwright who said
he would do it didn't do it another one
did didn't do it so in the end she my
captain said we'll do it listen there's
plenty of YouTube videos we just
need to do that we'll be fine and that's
what we did over many years and then we
passed we passed the inspection and now
she's being charted in New York Harbor I
am still waiting for the captain to call
going we're going down down and it's
that little bit in the front that you
did you have it yeah you said you
patched it I did I did I didn't say with
what yeah uh so this is the boat because
I'm also a Hemingway fan and I think
this is the boat that do you have this
boat in Cuba he did okay and uh I think
there's there's famous footage of him he
would he would go out and uh and Fish on
this boat yes
um and had it had a big chair like a big
fighting chair fighting chair yeah and
then uh he would
um you know unfortunately also drink a
lot yeah yeah yeah which uh which is you
know didn't help things for him no I was
in uh Cuba once I didn't get to see his
house but I was shooting something in
Havana when I was in a bar I was
shooting a travel show in in uh in in
Havana how long have you been doing this
travel show uh it was called Conan
Without Borders it's now we're shifting
into something else we're gonna give it
a difference with borders Conan with
yeah with orders responsible oh good um
Conan who stays within yes the county
lines mental borders yeah yeah it's just
me roaming around a very small portion
of Los Angeles mostly in the same Mall
brilliant uh but
um I was there and I went to a bar and I
guess it was one of Hemingway's favorite
bars in Havana and there's a big statue
as a life-size statue of him at the bar
so it's a life-size Hemingway in bronze
that's at the bar leaning against the
bar having a drink and I thought
you know he was an alcoholic yes I know
we're this is strange I know that this
is strange the applauding or the the
deifying yeah it was a little strange it
was uh yeah but whatever yeah so I know
after a few drinks I was happy to see
the statue and have your photo taken
yeah exactly yes several photos I know I
know I have this I have I do have this
this relationship with Hemingway kind of
I think it boils down to my own strange
relationship with kind of possibly what
I do and and and
do you say machismo yeah yes
so I kind of grapple with all these
things at time because sometimes I look
at what I do and I go my God this is so
I said oh oh I feel at times very
emasculated and therefore I want I
wonder sometimes if I overcompensate by
doing stupid things like this or whether
I you know but then at the end of the
day I enjoy it's a boat it's a beautiful
boat yeah I'm all for it I know and I
accept your invitation glorious
I started too heavily wow you're a damn
you're not quite as good an actress I
thought no no polishes no isn't there
yes
yes ah damn it asked me again there's
always a second take that's why I love
uh soap operas is that
um the and and certain kinds of TV
dramas is that an actor Will clearly
register displeasure but the other actor
all the ACT you know so you'll come to
me and you'll say well Conan I'll be
spending the weekend with you and I'll
go the weekend
and then you'll go problem and I'll go
not at all I know and then you're as
happy as a clown I know there's anyone
else did you did you blink for that
length of time what happened to your
brain in those four seconds I love to do
that in real life I know but I think I'm
happy that you got this boat I think
it's great well then come aboard anytime
you want Oh seriously children the
children Don't Go Near it anymore
they've only done like twice I think
it's you and me out on the ocean it's
pretty much it sending out distressed
calls you know we can't have immediately
I'll be sending out distress calls I
don't when it's slightly rocking yeah
say Conan we're fine why is it doing
that
why is there Motion in this vehicle Make
It Stop
um
I am going to well you're a busy man
you're a busy man you have things to do
you have worlds to conquer I say I do I
know but you know what every everyone I
learned to say it I used to say I have
nowhere to go and my time is yours yes I
was dead in Hollywood
so what I love is when you get the call
ahead of time uh Matthews and he's got a
lot going on he's very busy and so I
know that if I follow you down to the
lobby you're going to go across the
street yeah get a bubble tea no there's
a Biryani truck outside I clocked out on
the way in I'm no strainless stranger to
some Street Indian food
um I uh you are a pure delight uh you're
a crazy talented actor but also you are
hilariously funny and it is a personal
Grudge of mine
um I when when handsome uh talented
actors are also hilariously funny it
enrages me because at you this was I
like to say this was my consolation
prize for other things so you thank
you you thank you
it's not right no there's a turn of
phrase I've heard in many a time and
we're happily here again but you
thank you you know I always heard the
Welsh were just brilliant poets yes and
there you heard it you heard it right
there I hear it in Welsh in caligraphy
caddy gravy there they go perfectly said
Telegraph yeah yeah I'm gonna keep that
one yes that will come in handy I was
doing it I was doing a play once Off
Broadway and and I was playing not a
very a very likable character and I I
was I would say within half a block of
the theater after finishing and a woman
was walking in the opposite direction me
she was I was walking away from this she
was coming towards me and she just went
you're an and I thought and then
I thought oh she's seen the play yeah
and then I went hang on she's walking in
the opposite I'm walking from the
theater she's walking the opposite route
towards it so maybe she hasn't seen the
play and that stayed with me forever did
you ever find out no and it's I've
always wondered whether she's seen the
play or not then you married her and
then and that's when I knew
I'm so needy that's the woman I would
follow exactly is there any way I can
make it I played into every insecurity I
had uh well played Matthew uh good God
it's uh just it's just as the made my
day seriously thank you very much thank
you for the invitation as always oh my
God a true Joy yes I will come I will
haunt you on your boat please please do
it needs a ghost
hahaha